they're called super incredible the  strongest did you wash your hands with  soap did you dry them I did so are we  going to talk about it what the elephant  in the room weren't elephant  mom's new job  it's time to make some wrong things  right now they bring supers back into  the sunlight we need to change people's  perceptions about superheroes and  Elastigirl is our best play better than  me I'll watch the kids no problem  supposed to do a dad they wants to do it  I don't know that way why would they  change math math is math hello hey honey  everything's great  [Music]  he's in excellent health is freaky you  know it's crazy right to help my family  I gotta leave it to fix the law I gotta  break it you can to destroy kids can  have that choice thank you young man  combustion imminent what does that mean  it means fire Robert  [Music]  the screen slacker interrupts this  program for an important announced it up  it might get weird I'll be there  [Music]